welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
whose videos you need to watch a second
time to understand
and today we're going to be breaking
down exactly what a temporal pincer is
it's probably one of the most confusing
plot devices ever put to film
but we've got you covered in terms of
how it works why it's so effective
and how the movie itself is actually a
huge one going on before your very eyes
now there will be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't had time to watch tennant
yet
then i recommend that you go back and
check it out before seeing this video
unsubscribe from the channel if you've
been enjoying our tenant videos
and make sure you don't like the video
if you haven't watched it
what anyway with all out the way thank
you for clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown of the
temporal pincer
okay so the temporal pincer is used at
two key points in the film
firstly we see it happen during the car
chase and then at the end of the film
during the battle at stalisk 12. however
the film itself
is also a temporal pincer in some ways
with two
major characters carrying out one across
the decades
now before going into everything we have
to talk about how
time in the film works it's a relatively
simple concept
and though it's often referred to as
time travel in many ways it's not
we as humans experience time moving
forward in a sequential direction
this is typically referred to as cause
and effect
as in you roll a pen forward and it
moves forward
these are the laws of the universe
however those in the film who become
inverted
witness things moving backwards and thus
the effect is viewed as being the cause
so for them time moves in the opposite
direction with everything returning to
its source
rather than expanding from it now
everything that will happen
has happened and it is impossible to
change things because there only exists
one version of the events so when the
pen moves forward
it always moves forward and because we
saw it move forward
and know that that is what will always
happen when we invert
it must always move back during the car
chase which we'll get into more detail
in a bit
when viewing things normally we witness
inverted cars moving backwards
and this is because the driver in them
is going forward through time
however when we see things inverted they
are the ones that experience the cars
driving backwards
because for them time is moving in the
opposite direction
and thus the cars return to where they
were the moment before
continuously seeming to go backwards
it's basically
like playing a movie you see it play out
in a specific way
but if you hit the rewind button you'll
then watch the events play out exactly
the same
only this time backwards you cannot
alter or change them
because that is how they happened and
thus the characters in the film are very
much like us
viewers seeing things play out now this
idea of predestination
and things always happening the way that
they're supposed to very much plays into
the first real temporal pincer that we
see
a temporal pincer is basically the idea
that one can use knowledge of the
present and past
and then invert and go into the past and
participate in the events
exactly how they happened when saito is
on the boat at the end he states that
his knowledge of the future has helped
him vastly
and this is because throughout his life
saito has used temporal pincers as a way
to achieve victory
now this is exemplified in the scene
just before saito participates in the
car chase
he goes into one of the turnstiles and
then asks one of his team members to
relay the events of the car chase
exactly how it happened so sato has two
teams
one going forward and one going
backwards both receiving information
relayed by the others in order to carry
out the perfect heist
he waits at this point until the
protagonist is kidnapped and taken to
him
which is when he steps out with cat who
he had waiting to
sato then threatens to shoot her whilst
interrogating him
and after learning where everything is
he goes back in time
and takes part in the car chase the
protagonist lies to sato
so he doesn't actually get the algorithm
and the protagonist then follows him
back in time which is when we see the
events of the car chase
play out in reverse this method of
traveling backwards is so effective
that it's actually used by the tenant
group at the end of the movie
in order to carry out the skirmish at
stalisk 12.
now we predominantly see the briefing
through the eyes of the red team
and this is because the blue team have
already finished their operation
they have to remain in the shipping
containers so that the red team cannot
witness the end result
as if they see someone that perhaps
isn't there in the container
they may potentially divert from their
planned route in order to save them
so the blue team did the up at starlusk
12
and then returned to where the briefing
was in order to feed the information
forward
on what would be happening because of
this the red team now know exactly where
the explosion will take place
and they can plan around it when the
operation begins
the red teams set their watches to 10
minutes which will count down to the
explosion which will happen when the
timer hits zero
juxtaposing this the blue teams set
their watches to zero
and it counts up until the red team
arrives which just so happens to be
the 10 minute mark now both the red team
and blue team
are actually merely there to carry out a
diversion that will make the future
sator
believe that the algorithm was buried
when we see michael kane in the film
he states that two weeks prior during
the opera scene
there was an explosion at saito's old
home which we learn is stalisk 12.
sator 2 would know of this and he would
believe that that was his team in the
future
traveling back to that moment to bury
the algorithm so that people in the
future could find it
the entire plot of the movie is
basically to make sato believe that the
algorithm is buried
so that saito thinks his mission is
successful when really a splinter group
led by the protagonist
are going to break into the bunker steal
the algorithm
and then set off the explosion so that
it seems like it was buried
when really they had it all along does
that make sense
i think you know what i think i think it
i think it does anyway
michael kane actually knew the entire
events that were going to happen
and that the algorithm didn't get buried
because the world didn't end
and all that he was doing was merely
setting up the dominoes to knock them
all down whilst putting the protagonist
on a path that would lead to him going
back in time
and stopping the algorithm from being
buried he knew he wasn't in any danger
which is probably why he was just
chilling out and hanging around at a
fancy restaurant
and all he really was was another cog in
the machine that would keep the wheels
spinning the way that they were supposed
to
now he's one of many and the film itself
should actually be viewed as a temporal
pincer as a whole
as we've learned in order for a temporal
pincer we need to have two teams
and in the film these are shown using
the colours red and blue
as it requires two people moving in
different directions
we need to find out who these characters
are in the film in order for this theory
to be correct
now the first one that we know for
definite is neil and neil is actually
the person that has moved backwards
throughout the film
and we learn that he was recruited by an
older version of the protagonist from
the future
thus neil is the blue team member and
the protagonist
is there for the red neil knows more
than he should
because he's already been briefed on
everything that will happen by the
protagonist
who has watched it all play out in the
future in the future
we know that he recruits neil and then
sends him back fully briefed on what
will happen
and this should be viewed as a continual
loop neil plays his part and then
through his journey travels back to this
moment at the end of the movie with the
protagonist
and he gives him his part of the
algorithm to keep he then briefs him on
what his mission is
and that is to travel forward through
the future recruit neil and then send
him back so that he can partake in the
temporal pincer
we never actually meet the elder version
of the protagonist
but we know that he succeeds in his
mission because neil is able to come
back to this moment
and complete his objective informing the
protagonist that he must continue
forward to recruit neil
the protagonist in the future is so
clued up on how everything will happen
because he lived through it when he was
younger and he then used this knowledge
to put all of the key players in place
such as priya
the guy on the boat and michael kane who
yes
i know his character is not called
michael kane now the protagonist
tells neil that he has to guide his past
version into saving the world
in order so that he can go to the future
and send neil back to guide him into
saving the world
as i said it's a complete perfect loop
in which the future relies on the past
just as much as the pastoralized in the
future hopefully
hopefully that helped you get your head
around it and that's pretty much the
entire temporal pincer in a nutshell
and though it's it's a bit difficult to
understand at first
once you see everything for the
continual loop that it is
it makes a lot more sense now obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
movie
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our fall
breakdown of neil's timeline which is
going to be linked at the end
we go over his entire run throughout the
movie and even before
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more we're also giving
away a free copy of the christopher
nolan collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe
to the channel and drop a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you being the best i've been definition
and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you